l'avancée russe donc s'accélère dans le
donbass en ukraine après la chute de
l'iscid science qui est la prise totale
de la région de lougansk les troupes de
vladimir poutine ont mis le cap un peu
plus à l'ouest elles seraient à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres à peine de ce lot
violence cas présent vous retrouvez à
kiev gilbert crack vous êtes notre
correspondant en ukraine bonjour
gulliver les autorités locales parlent
de très violents bombardements
dans cette région
oui un peu comme hier matin en fait les
militaires ukrainien dont le rapport
matinale parle d'un succès pour les
forces du craignant à repousser une
tentative d'avancée sur le sol vers la
viande est aussi cramatte or ce que
notamment avec des combats près de 10
villages dolina qui est au nord ouest
d'oslo vienne sq donc je pense que les
ukrainiens ont du succès en stoppant
pour le moment l'avancée rue sur le sol
mais les bombardements continus de
manière très intense sur les trois
grandes villes de la région de donetsk
qui restent aux mains des ukrainiens bac
mouthe slovensko et cramatte osc et il y
a eu des frappes aussi à d'autres
endroits en ukraine notamment à dans la
région d'ath melnitz qui dans l'ouest du
pays ou encore dans la région de rare
qu'yves / archives même hier j'ai parlé
à une soldate qui était jusqu'à
récemment dans la région dach qu'yves où
elle disait que les avancées ukrainienne
les contre offensive dans cette région
de harkis fpt ont été éclairement
stopper les soldats ukrainiens sont
restés bloqués dans leurs tranchées dont
la région de harkis va subir des
bombardements intensément durant des
semaines et quel est le moral
précisément de ces troubles ukrainienne
face à cet homme large offensive russe
alors justement je pense que globalement
dans le pays en ukraine il y a encore ce
sentiment que c'est vraiment une quête
existentielle pour ce pays et qu'il faut
absolument maintenir le moral haute mais
c'est très difficile
les experts disent qu'un soldat ne doit
pas passer plus que deux semaines sous
des bombardements des tirs d'artillerie
intensifs pour éviter des troubles
psychologiques et là vous avez des
soldats qui reste un mois même plus même
deux mois sans avoir de pause donc
forcément sur certains d'entre eux c'est
trauma psychologique se produisent et la
soldate à qui j'ai parlé hier parler
aussi de problèmes dans la direction les
officiers de plus bas rend les
directeurs d'unités par exemple qu'ils
n'avaient pas assez d'expérience même
pour pouvoir aider les nouveaux recrus
les gens qui ont été mobilisés par
exemple à garder le moral la situation
est très dangereuse il est très facile
même si on est très engagé pour protéger
son pays de prendre peur et de panique
et si vous voulez les mouvements de
panique peuvent se produire assez
rapidement quand les pertes sont aussi
grandes que ce que l'ukraine est en
train de subir en ce moment l'univers
craag à kiev pour france24 merci
beaucoup